is attacked by white's rook he will win  okay a flashy tactic actually there from  hikara nakamura he used his knight to  take a pawn with a check he was going  for checkmate and now just retreating  the black knight  it's level pawns but black's extra night  will count  hikaru bobbing his head because he knows  the wind is in sight the black king is  now about to reach safety and no more  tricks for artemis  the russian just fighting on  but it's going to be in vain  it looks like he's about ready to resign  our here our time we have has had a good  tournament so far i think he's won four  matches  but also lost uh  uh three matches sorry tamiya so far  yeah he's been great been really  entertaining the russian but this game  he is going down look at this the black  pawn  pushing forward now the white king is  going to uh come under fire and there we  go we have a result hikara nakamura  takes it ah that looks very annoying for  vladi's lava time and he still has two  games to go